yo I think I can rap to like a bunch of
other reactors I'm gonna give a shot got
some some things to say
ponies homies it's a burst your bubble
but it's on set and your channel you've
got nothing to show nothing I looked you
up load up on those boats rich in
channels all [ __ ] they got nowhere with
YouTube it don't fit
say it making views from a check of the
react overs well it's perverse cuz tell
me what's the worst mind your own
business do your own thing you know just
jealous cuz I'm attaining what you dream
in your videos a week what do you offer
that is unique you got no content got no
comments to reply back to when attack us
dudes giving us attitude we'll sit down
down on sucks show some gratitude
get some reactive dudes and rapper
abusers going down the wrong Avenue this
week exist we co-exist and we versa so
if you're the one who bit this then
you're must miss [ __ ] hit list guess
what though I don't disagree cuz he's
honest do see what you do see most
reject is a [ __ ] there's no benefit to
watching you just sit same old laughter
same old news in Oz writable applause
just a pointless cost so avoid this all
up put your pointment on fractions over
show is over video ends no words to lend
minimal abysmal shows no critical
nothing additional yet your video was
still admissible
many of these wannabe reactors are just
horrible actors in the continuing a
boring person all you produce this
quantity with low production quality
tightly held bingo fix your [ __ ] audio
get a [ __ ] camera gets the [ __ ]
lights give some charisma give some
insights well forget it
ernõ credit can't even earn it just
works at a bad air breakfast that's
fucked-up thing it does just thing it
sucks so much those MOOCs are dumb with
luck but I got this thing done without
them look the first year of the real
rejects I'll never forget my dad had
died my gramma had my relationship had
died gonna get a handle became suicidal
but thank you to the early subscribers
is all I had was my channel I worked
like a freak 70 hours a week full-time
job course I'm on my fortune call me a
slob don't see you taking action huh
behind a keyboard call me lazy but I
work on the YouTube daily it's
perception of our reaction that all we
do is sit back and star laugh and had to
be patient to buy equipment started the
movement of others improvements first
one its auto reactant review now all
these dudes copy how I do first one not
to [ __ ] from my computer actually bought
a [ __ ] camera first when a great
an actual set first want to bring on a
hot ass guess first wanna throw in edits
goddamn [ __ ] was all my credit so
[ __ ] the new players and [ __ ] you
haters call me a [ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
at least that shot my face oh no this
trace below and above your waist as a
waste all these people be saying they
may wear the reactions got my
subtractions well I'm the person
couldn't resist to see the playlist and
it consists of all the playlists that I
created before you even existed now all
you guys cover movie reviews and movie
news but no excuses are all a part of
our prologue and back to being the
underdog working on some brand new songs
proven all these haters wrong
the mountains more than opinions going
through stages posting sketches that's
my last name who's the best if I'll
write the answers yes that's right I
right that's right I act by right that's
right I multiply test Elsa no wrecks
show some respect
why don't you get that I also wear it
I'm a hungry dog that likes to vlog look
at the clock like that one more I also
on bucks Mike dick to the blower limited
edition if for the suspicion don't
forget and no regrets and you came to
the channel soap welcome to though
really checks don't forget him no regret
city came to the channel so welcome to
the real rejects don't forget in no
regrets that he came to the channel so
welcome to the real rejects did it Ryan
you prove all these haters wrong people
are like reactions are stupid and then
they're like there's no content but then
people are making content off of our we
have no content so doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense and some of you guys just
you're not entertained watch I'm sorry
to tell you he was really entertaining
to watch but I'm like the real deal you
know like I get why people watch me I'm
[ __ ] awesome I'm sexy go masturbate
right now
they feel Ryan right I feel like people
expect me to say thank you for all your
support
well [ __ ] pissed that I'm leaving I
didn't absolutely [ __ ] [ __ ] you Jerry
[ __ ] all the rejects [ __ ] every one of
the rejects [ __ ] [ __ ] you hey come on
dude [ __ ] you
hey I only came here because I was
feeling gross the way and I will share
hell you know oh we're not friends
anymore you're a nice guy you're a nice
guy but that [ __ ] don't cut it when
you're [ __ ] around like this [ __ ]
digging around
anyway I'm reasons to Jerry on instagram
my name's not even Jerry